lors du déjeuner a beau avoir sommé le
calme règne dans le 11e arrondissement
de la capitale
dans ce restaurant voisin du métro
oberkampf la terrasse restent vides et
l'affluence à l'intérieur est bien
inférieur à la normale après les
annonces doligé véran lundi dernier les
restaurateurs exerçant en zone d' alerte
maximale ont dû s'adapter
parmi les nouvelles restrictions la
prise de coordonnées des clients afin de
pouvoir les prévenir si un cas de kovy
19 et décelés parmi la clientèle où le
personnel j'ai choisi justement d'avoir
un dossier de faire des félibres
justement pour ça que les gens et trop
de tâches avant avec tous les
coordonnées des clients qui passent on
avait quand même envie de respecter une
certaine confidentialité si ça te
rassurer les gens ça te rassure m le
gouvernement où il n'y a pas de problème
on les met en place et de ton et veiller
à tout ce qu'on nous a demandé depuis le
début et on n'est pas réfractaire à
faire les choses qui font aisément mis
en place la collecte de coordonnées des
clients posent questions parmi ces
derniers entre soupçons d' intrusion
dans la vie privée et dispositifs
essentiels pour la protection de la
population
la prise de coordonner dans les
restaurants divise ses conflits
franck prévôt tracé rien mais en même
temps donner le montant
je suis désolé ça les cartes de noël
quand même une une notion de sécurité
médicale déjà systran fonctionne mal
tentation insiste là-dessus toute
manière on expliquer quoi qu'il en soit
le jeu remplir parole ça veut dire quoi
que je ne remplissent pas
tout le monde fait attention à l'aspect
priorité à la santé ou traçage des
données le débat pourrait bien perdurer
prévu initialement pour deux semaines
ces mesures permettent à la profession
de travailler malgré la situation
sanitaire compliqué pour autant les
restaurateurs voient leur chiffre
d'affaires chuter brusquement dans
l'établissement de kati l'affluence a
chuté de moitié à cause de la pandémie
de kobe de 19